joining us now on the dam pad show Chris
Mannix of Yahoo Sports covers boxing
covers MBA he was out in Los Angeles and
still is Chris right off the bat when
you heard that we were hosting today and
we didn't call you your thoughts went to
where well I mean my immediate reaction
was why I am in LA so that would have
been challenging however I'm not that
far from the direct TV studio here so I
probably could have done it like
remotely if they could have set that up
in in some way from like Rich Eisen
chair but let me ask you guys this like
over under until NBCSN cuts to like
speedboat racing you know guys that's a
great call there's some like also and
also like I mean you could also a second
over-under before audience starts
showing you know NYPD Blue reruns like I
mean I see the t's on NBCSN Dubai
equestrian championships coming up next
I didn't see that I think audience has
mr. Mercedes rear I don't go anywhere
alright Mannix you're out in LA you were
at the press conference for the LA
Lakers is that one of the bigger scenes
that you've been part of in NBA history
I mean look it had a kind of a deep in
the playoffs feel to it in terms of
number of media members everybody
nationally was represented you know the
local papers are all kind of doubling up
on their Laker coverage this year what I
thought was kind of goofy was the fact
that the Clippers held their media day
on the exact same day I mean if you're
the Clippers and and you want to have
any hope of getting covered why not do
it like the day before the day after I
mean I can't I don't even know who was
at the Clippers Media Day but it was it
was a big contingent I mean for obvious
reasons I mean I what was interesting
was you know LeBron spoke at noon
eastern and when liberal in in Pacific
when LeBron got up everybody kind of
followed him around as he went from
station to station doing all the the
requisite you know duties he had to do
as a player when Luke Walton sat down
next there was like seven people there
you know
to question him because everybody was
following LeBron so it just kind of sort
of exemplified what this year's gonna be
like with people following every step
LeBron takes Chris yesterday on the show
we talked about summer LeBrons comments
that he doesn't necessarily need to win
a championship this year that's how it
not how he's gonna define success what's
the reaction in LA - how LeBron sort of
entered that situation I mean look I
think people that know basketball are
realists I mean LeBron got jumped on for
that comment Perloff on on Monday and I
don't know what do you expect the guy to
say be like well well you know there's
no there's only one champion but we
could be that champion does anybody
believe that that team is is going to be
a champion I mean I think what he wants
to do this year is be a part of
developing the guys that are eventually
going to be part of a team that's going
to compete for a championship I mean
there are a lot of mercenaries on that
team we've talked about this before but
the one-year deal guys the Rondo's the
the Lance Stephenson that's not really
LeBrons priority it's LeBron priority is
Brandon Ingram
it's Kyle Kuzma it's the guys that that
he needs to win championships down the
line if he can help them take the next
step I think he'll consider that a
successful season and that's a realistic
outcome for the year so Chris then how
much do we read into Luke Walton
starting Rondo this season over Lonzo
ball and his development I mean it's
interesting you know the fact is that
you know Lonzo hasn't played basketball
all summer because he's been coming to
getting off that knee injury I mean the
fact is that
Lonzo still is only participating in
half the training camp stuff he didn't
participate yesterday in the afternoon
session he participated in the evening
session but that was all non-contact
stuff so lonzo's got a long way to go he
may not even be ready to go at full
strength had the start of the season
what's going to be interesting you know
for multiple reasons is what happens
with lonzo's all the way back in you
know November or early December
I mean Rondo I asked him this at the end
of the the media day on Monday but he
when he gets that starting job he's
not going to give it up I mean people
are kind of painting Rondo is his mentor
or Big Brother righto 32 years old on a
one-year deal he's coming off a
brilliant postseason performance with
the pelicans last year he's not there to
be a backup and be you know just like
this guide for Lonzo ball he's there to
play he's there to win and he's there to
get that next contract so you know when
I used to work combustible with you guys
earlier in the offseason this was kind
of what I was talking about you know the
point guard position because when you
throw Lavar ball into the mix and levar
hasn't really been around or spoken much
the last couple of months it has the
potential to be really really wild that
spot Chris Mannix of Yahoo Sports
joining us now in the Dan Patrick show
which do you find more fascinating how
boogie Cousins is gonna fit in on the
court with Golden State or how Carmelo
Anthony is gonna fit in hardcore with
Houston
I think Carmelo because I don't know
when cousins coming back I mean cousins
you know probably be January early
February maybe the all-star break when
cousins comes back and they're not gonna
rush him he's not really doing much
right now he's overcoming he's trying to
overcome an injury that nobody comes
back well from in that first year and
some guys don't come back well from at
all
Carmelo was just I mean that whole thing
is just fascinating I mean Carmelo
Anthony was the reason that Mike
D'Antoni quit in New York not our reason
V reason that he quit in New York
several years ago now they're together
and singing Kumbaya I mean it's like a
it's a forced marriage I know when I
felt like it was a desperate move for
the Rockets who had lost Trevor Ariza
with lost lukla by moot a defense was
their identity last season I mean they
had great offensive players but they're
a top-ten defensive team that's not what
Carmelo does is he willing to come off
the bench I mean that from day one I
think that's gonna be interesting
whereas cousins I mean he's just icing
on the cake I mean they've won without
cousins they can win with them
Carmelo it could tip the scales one way
or the other for the Rockets Chris we're
kind of considering jumping on a
bandwagon here at the DP show there are
all of a sudden a lot of green shirts a
lot of Boston Celtics fans in the
Milford mancave are they the team to
beat in the East and if not them who
I mean yeah I mean Toronto is is a
threat and you know Kawhi Leonard
talking about being healthy and looking
you know in good shape at the press
conferences and early in training camp
that certainly is a good sign for the
Raptors but I think the Celtics are
gonna come out fast
I think that when 65 games I think
they're gonna be the class of the
Eastern Conference all season longer be
there they're our hockey team guys they
confirm two lines out there a love of
playoff quality talents I mean you know
that they I like the what wouldn't
Marcus Morris dubbed the second unit BW
a bench with attitude I mean those guys
are all players who who believe they
could be starters and all with something
to prove going into this season so I
think they're gonna be just lethal all
year long I mean Toronto is good
Philadelphia is okay Milwaukee is okay
but I think Boston is gonna be the class
of the Congress Chris since I'm known
for my left turns and just destroying
the show and taking it in the opposite
direction do we really care about
another nice preamble so we really care
about another Pacquiao Mayweather fight
how do you sell the world on that event
that's not just a big scam I don't I
mean that's I don't I don't know what to
compare that to look put it this way I
didn't go to to Mayweather McGregor
because I knew the outcome I didn't care
I will not go to Pacquiao Mayweather
because I know the outcome and I don't
care I you know Mayweather wants to come
back and fight one of the Young Lions in
147 pounds of vision you know to prove
that he's still a man at 42 years old or
whatever great he'll come back for Errol
Spence come back for Terence Crawford
if Pacquiao wants to fight Amir Khan
which is actually a good fight overseas
I'd love to see that sign me up
with those two getting back in the ring
together I just don't care more to the
point it's Charlie Brown illusi guys I
know I said this before with McGregor
and I was wrong Pacquiao Mayweather is
not gonna happen
I mean Mayweather he made the
announcement on the day of the Canelo
Alvarez fight just to screw with Oscar
De La Hoya because he hates austell Hoya
right and he wants to screw with his his
uh his fight so I don't think it's gonna
happen
Mayweather doesn't fight outside the US
Pacquiao owes the IRS like from what I
was told like thirty two million dollars
he's never gonna fight the u.s. high
ever again there's too many obstacles to
make a fight like that happen
anacs going back to the lakers press
conference i want to commend you for
cycling up to lebron and getting a lot
of national airtime a lot of pictures
with you near him how do you work that
move um you know I had my selfie stick
out so I cleared some space in that spot
but yeah just get there you're ten
minutes early and jockey for position
with the nine thousand cameras that are
gonna be around all season long those
goggles are just a mess though I mean
it's just TV somebody asked look I mean
I'm not trying to mock other PR
reporters there but somebody's like
asking like how do you get the the
respect of LA like really he has the
respect of LA signed a 4-year deal to to
play for the Lakers I mean he he's also
getting asked guys about like chuckling
off the court stuff like he's got all
the stuff and juggling two things on
that real quick one he's not editing raw
footage here like he's not going to be
in in the back you know just you know
he's not a grip on one of his movie
shoots he's not the best boy and key
grip he's not and and the other thing is
to like everybody's like saying it's all
la like July 2nd when LeBron signed HBO
didn't greenlight the shop Showtime
didn't greenlight shut up and dribble
spacejam to didn't come about in the
last two months this stuff has been in
the works for months and months and
months in other words if LeBron James
was a San Antonio spur he still have all
this stuff that was going on so you know
trying to tie LA into all this is a bit
ridiculous right Mannix quickly I got a
humid take on the NBA and TV ratings
this year I think that the NBA and TNT
and Turner should get together and bump
up the Golden State work national games
and the Lakers national games because
these are the two teams I'll work in the
Celtics that play nationally and a lot
of the Laker warrior games start at
10:30 Eastern and you're losing a lot of
metro areas that watch a lot of
basketball if you could somehow bump
those games up to a 9:30 a.m. tip all of
a sudden you can at least get the first
quarter or first half of the Eastern NBA
viewer 9:30 a.m.
I'm sorry 9:30 p.m. Eastern tip for the
game so they would start 6:30 on the
p.m. on the west coast yeah you know
they do that in the finals a lot that's
actually I mean I thought you're gonna
say something completely absurd but
that's
totally absurd you know they did the
finals games all started nine ish so
west coast they're starting at six it's
something I think is worth exploring
because of all did the number of games
that are going to take place you're
right about the games that matter I mean
if you talk to so like you know web
editors and web writers they're like
three teams that are going to really
resonate this year and click in terms of
web traffic it's the Warriors it's the
Lakers is the Celtics those are the
three most interesting storylines all
year the three teams that are going to
be on national TV the most so yeah move
it all up you know take take advantage
of that that East Coast audience my plan
at nine five thirty
all right Chris our old friend Lee
Jenkins is now with the Clippers Sports
Illustrated writer if you got a call
from let's say the Denver Nuggets we
want you in the scouting department
would you take such an offer no because
I suck as a scout I mean like I mean you
can I mean just go back and look at all
my takes from this show like like I'm
gonna have them like I would have taken
yeah I was taken like Ricky Rubio number
one that would have taken like I mean I
don't but that's a grind man I respect
Lee for doing it and I understand why
he's doing it because Lee can always
turn around three years from now and go
back to the same job and be the exact
same guy but I didn't I don't I don't
have any appetite for that I'd like to
be like a consultant on that where
somebody's calls me was like what do you
think of this guy but don't put that
kind of pressure on my shoulders to be
the day-to-day you know operations guy
yes so it's actually possible your
commentary and this show has cost you
those opportunities Wow hey how about
that Mannix guy be like no it's scalding
all over the Spanish players like all
over Rubio I agree with that like people
might feel might have thought like well
Maddox is uh a pretty smart guy right
some decent calls but wait a minute he
he's guessing that like Rafael rojos
gonna be Rookie of the Year and I mean
it
you're Dante you're Dante Exum manifesto
sure cost you a few gigs my team would
be like I would be great in San Antonio
because the international flavor of my
team's will always be it'll always be
well-represented Maddox thanks a lot for
joining the show go back to sleep hope
the hair is working out for you
hey thanks to the NBCSN audience for
watching a rerun of NASCAR America
during the stop be careful don't go
there
that was Chris Mannix of Yahoo's Yahoo
Sports covers the NBA for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]